first job a pomegranate marinade for the
quail which have been cut in half and
flattened on this one yeah it's tiny so
it's almost like a sort of nice entrance
into eating something slightly gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt pepper and all spatchcock means
is that the rib cage has been taken out
and they're flattened down and because
the bird is so delicate its flattened to
cook evenly and it really is a nice sort
of lights' gamey dense chicken flavor so
we're toast the spices when you think of
middle-eastern food is packed with
amazing flavors tell us printer
coriander a teaspoon of cumin a nice
little seasoning and salt so we toast
them now intensifying the flavor and
they start smoking lightly that's a nice
indication that they're ready to grind
away
so the best thing man I send up close
today thank you looking your tummy's out
I thought was the quail or tummy this
hand here keeps it nice and firm and you
grind that into a nice powder for Betty
please sounds so good doesn't it yeah so
to get that in really go around the
outside and that grinds up
I'm gonna round up SM water more times
and you kiss boys squeeze the garlic in
next love volleyball okay then wait to
pour six tablespoons please
so that is pomegranate molasses says
like an aged balsamic vinegar but really
reduced down give that a nice big sell
no taste it's sweet but sour oh it is so
good that no take a nice spoon put it
inside the quail you can even do this
the night before just pop them in the
fridge let the Crowell marinate anywhere
from half now to overnight the quails
are marinated now they're ready to cook
I saw pan mm-hmm pick up your quail and
skin side down first okay get all that
nice color and always open them up as
well in the pan
okay I'm gonna get that skin crispy
that's right
smell that pomegranate I can really
smell it smells so good
if you're all that marinate in there you
know cook with it as well don't waste it
listen 12 to 15 minutes in the oven a
little touch of water in
[Music]
bring that up to the ball in the oven
180 for 12 to 15 minutes okay yeah the
final job before serving a hurry butter
bean salad to go with Mike well in
pomegranate molasses now one of the
things that I love about Middle East and
salads is the sort of crunch and the
color as well butter beans it's gonna be
the base of our salad from their little
relishes and sort of top and tell them
get them like that
and throw them in there's nothing small
and dainty in there okay so with the
spring onions nice we can use the greens
and the wasps when you slice along that
way this time to get those nice light
shards okay yep now the croutons are
made out of these little pitabread just
slice lengthwise oh yes
so this cell is all about texture so
cucumber okay and take out your seeds
how comes you're taking the seeds out it
just makes the salad very watery she can
produce delicious oh yeah you've got me
going you really got me going this is
far more important trust me
who needs exams where you can cook for
that's fine it's fine it's fine
beer chef for a living have a proper job
don't take your things out like that
you'll be thumbless let's code now you
can bring from there take your nice
vibrant tomatoes it's nice down
call me sis like a Greek salad is a
little colors it resembles that that's
right and with a celery yeah that place
so we need some mint and parsley
I want you sprinkling it in there it
really makes it through the herbs give
it that nice kind of freshness mm-hmm
but I want a bit of a bite in there now
so just carefully pick now you can and
then just talk on top so you got a bit
of fruitiness now is it a salad for
crunch
simply cut up whole pit of breads fry in
a really hot pan with olive oil into a
wonderfully golden crispy and
irresistible out into a sieve
okay
next a sprinkle of sumac as a dried
fruit in Middle East the zest of a lemon
and the juice then a drizzle of olive
oil and last but not least my crunchy
pitter croutons mixing new hands a nice
and just new fingertips then I guess we
just mix very good and doesn't crush
anything but then let's just take a
little bean Wow delicious nice now
quail it's got that Rudi mmm sort of
toasted almost like a sort of light
barbecue flavor
oh wait try it Wow just finally lemon
juice it just lightens everything up a
little bit and it goes so well with the
pomegranate now just mm-hmm
Wow it'll smell better than any boy
friend you'll ever have okay good that's
good
how delicious is that that's so
delicious